so I'm going to tell you about a part of
the work I did during my PhD thesis at
Carnegie Mellon and this is joint work
with my advisor Eric and the song comer
and anchor so during the bread shop
we've heard a lot about models of
network so we had the random
distributions over networks and if one
is given a network then we can do all
nice kinds of things like you can
visualize the complex system we can
detect communities we can predict the
size of a cascade etc but in a number of
problems we actually do not get to see a
network we don't know which objects
interact with each other and the focus
of this talk is going to be how can we
infer connections between objects in
particular I'm going to be interested in
a scenario where we can cheaply measure
certain things for example in the
context of biology we can measure gene
expression profiles and then we would
like to infer which genes interact to
drive a development of fruit fly for
example so the setup will be that we can
obtain some measurements over a system
that changes over time and then based on
these measurements that can be cheaply
collected we would like to infer
something about the underlying complex
system so that's going to be the goal of
the talk and so why do we care about is
promising in particular often performing
experiments and trying to understand
when two genes interact and when do they
interact is expensive so hopefully by
having in a mathematical model of that
can provide some insight into this
complex system we can do this uncovering
more cheaply okay so summarize we would
like to infer some network that tells us
about interactions between genes that
drive cell division process so
development of a fruit fly
and we would like to infer these
networks from data that can be cheaply
collected over time so in particular we
have connections interactions between
objects that the changing over time and
we have data that is collected over time
and there are a number of challenges we
will be focusing on problems where the
number of observations is smaller than
the number of parameters in the model
that would like to make inference about
and so we will utilize we will assume
some structure that underlies the
complex system at hand okay and there
are the challenges that we thought about
but we won't be talking about those here
so the talk is going to please see this
fall's I'm going to provide you an
overview of how Marco networks i use to
learn conditional independent
conditional independence assumptions
between objects and how we can infer
these conditional independence a--'s
from ID data then we will combine these
techniques with some ideas that the
commonly used in nonparametric
aggressions like Colonel smoothing and
utilization using total variation norms
I will provide you an application to a
data set then maybe we can talk about
some theoretical results maybe not we'll
see okay so to start off a Markham
network consists of two things we have a
random vector X are and the graph that's
associated with this vector the graph
each node in the graph corresponds to a
component of a random vector and edges
in the graph represent conditional
independence assumptions and so
hopefully this okay so this is a useful
representation of associations between
components of this vector in particular
the missing edge in a graph indicates
that two components of the random vector
are conditionally independent and our
goal is going to be
to learn this graph structure that
analyze a probability distribution p
according to which ex is this related to
common examples are Gaussian Marco
networks and Isaac model and these are
very nice models because the probability
distribution is parametrized by the
first two moments and in particular the
inverse of covariance matrix encodes the
structure that you're trying to learn in
particular if there is a 0 in the
precision matrix this means that the two
components a conditional independent
given all the other components and
similarly for the discrete networks
again the model is parametrized by the
first two moments and if theta a b is
equal to 0 that means that nodes a and b
are not conditional independent so the
task that we have in front ourselveses
can we learn the structure for graph
given ID data and so this has been
started a lot in the past seven years
say in the high dimensional context at
least and in the classical set up there
is a nice oviya paper by Dutton and
perrimon would they say that in the if
that are Gaussian looking before max is
maximum likelihood estimation and test
with a an element of the precision
matrix is zero zero in the context of
discrete networks in general it is hard
to learn the structure but you're
interested in the context then the
number of parameters is much larger than
the sample size and so recently one
proposal is to not racin but in 2006
Manhattan will not had a proposal to
estimate a structure of gossamer core
network by using the following
observation that conditional
distribution of one not given all the
others the parameters of this
conditional distribution can be
estimated by sewing the following
penalized surah likelihood
objective and then the parameters that a
nonzero here will indicate what is the
neighborhood of a node okay so roughly
this works as follows we have we would
like to infer graph between these nodes
so conditional dependencies between
these nodes with form following
objective problem for node 1 we solve
the problem the nonzero coefficients
tell us who are the neighbors of node 1
by repeating this for each node we are
going to learn the structure of whole
graph and this is nice because it works
both for discrete graphical models for
Gaussian graphic malls if a node
conditional distribution is a member of
exponential family etc so it's a very
nice idea that carries over to a number
of distributions and furthermore it
probably recovers the graph structure
under some conditions and we have fast
estimation procedures for solving this
optimization problem at each given node
so what we are going to do is we are
going to extend this procedure to more
general setting so I'm going to add any
question so the setup that you are
interested in is when we have data that
is collected over time and we like to
infer these parameters that hopefully
give a sentence about this process over
time and in this setting we have a
vector for nodal observations at each
time point t which is disputed calling
distribution index by a parameter theta
of T this is going to we are going to
allow this parameter to change over time
and G of T is just telling us what the
conditional independence assumptions at
time point t are so in particular it
tells us would are the nonzero
parameters of water the nonzero
components of this parameter vector
pointing okay so we're going to try to
estimate theta but then once we
estimated I will will be able to read
off conditional independence structure
hopefully and we are going to use the
general estimation framework given a
data we would like to penalize a
negative log likelihood when we are
maximizing the penalize log likelihood
and this term is going to measure the
fit of the model to the data locally and
the penalty is going to enforce
different assumptions on how does the
network change over time and I'm going
to tell you about two scenarios one is
when we have smoothly evolving networks
in particular the underlying parameter
vector theta as a function of time is
smooth in some sense in another case
when we have an abrupt change or some
discontinuity in our parameter vector
theta so in the context of smooth
networks we are going to use a local
conditional likelihood glocal likelihood
to estimate the graph at certain
estimate a network at a certain point
towel and the case of abrupt changes
we're going to estimate these networks
simultaneously but by enforcing that the
difference between parameters associated
to each edge to be small for adjacent
time points okay so just to give you an
illustration how this works recall we
have a log of conditional likelihood we
have a weight that decreases as we move
away from a time point out which we
would like to infer the network and then
we are solving a following optimization
problem for each a at the teach time
point out at which you would like to
infer the network so this term ensures
that
the estimator is going to be smooth well
the penalty is going to ensure that the
network estimated that each time point
is going to be spots so each
neighborhood is going to be spas and so
then we are going to do this at multiple
time points tao to get some insights
about how does the network evolve all
the time and so each optimization
problem can be so reasonably quickly
using advances in l1 penalized the
solvers of use that able to solve this
problem next we are going to briefly
discuss how to estimate networks who
jumps so here the model is slightly
different so suppose that these are our
parameters so theta 1 2 is the parameter
associated to edge between node 1 and
node to a time point t and this is the
plot of it as a functional over time
then we see that there are four blocks
where the network is constant so we have
here point two point five point seven
etc where these changes in behavior the
founder there's a change in an
underlying structure so the goal here is
to identify where these change points
occur and then to identify a network at
each corresponding block to do this we
are going to again solve penalized to
the likelihood objective the first term
here ensures a bias is the estimation
towards sparse networks at each time
point t well the second thumb ensures
that the difference between parameters
at Jason ten points is small so this is
going to enforce the whole vector at
time point t and 10.2 plus one is either
0 not zero and so this is motivated by a
fuse penalty for example in the
context of alesso with the difference
that here we use l2 norm to enforce to
shrink the call vector of differences
during 0 okay and again we can solve
this subject this optimization problem
efficiently and maybe just to compare
with the previous setup here we
obtaining a network simultaneously for
all n data points whereas previously we
had to solve an optimization problem to
obtain the network only locally it for
10 point out okay and so let me show you
briefly an application how would one use
this to an explorer a real system so I'm
going to focus on estimation of smoothly
changing networks an application is
going to be to trying to understand
which genes interact to drive
development of a fruit fly so the data
is quite old from our time at all in two
thousand second it consists of 66 micro
measurements that were collected through
a full life cycle of genetically
identical fruit flies so we have
independent observation at each time
point from a genetically identical fruit
fly and these observations are bucketed
into four stages we have number of
observations during the embryo stage and
then as the organism becomes older we
have fewer measurements they owe the
measurements are taken the place
frequently so here you have maybe few
ever if you are isn't here a few days
would pass between we obtained mercury
emissions and we are focusing our
analysis the subset of about 600 genes
that are known to be related to
development of organism okay so what
i'll be uploading here is just how the
condition the estimated conditional
independence is at each time point so
now it much can be
seen here but let me try to illustrate
how this could be used if we put
post-process the estimated so what we
are plotting here is we on the outer
circle we have plotted a number of
clusters and so each cluster represents
a collection of nodes and then we
connect two clusters if there's an edge
going from one cluster to the other
cluster and we acknowledges within nodes
in one cluster and so this is only to
illustrate that at certain points
there's a transition in the behavior of
which genes interact for example when
the wings start to develop in the adult
stage of an organism days a myth there's
a huge change between two consecutive
time points because the genes that are
involved in developing mental things
have a conditionally dependent according
to our graham when in the earlier stage
these same clusters interact with the
other clusters a change which could
illustrate that they perform potentially
different function at an early stage but
this is just the annales and
illustrative example of how this could
be used yes yes the nodes of clusters of
genes so edge between two clusters of
genes exists if our algorithm has
inferred that gene in one class change
in another cluster of conditional a
dependent
so that this under our model so we
assume that distribution of micro
measurements falls Gaussian distribution
if you don't want to make that
assumption then what I'm saying is that
partial correlations between estimated
partial correlation between new
components of random vector R is nonzero
pictures you're stable pictures or words
or some cross validation how do you
choose realization so we were maximizing
vse criteria for the parameter H we kind
of picked it in an ad hoc way and I
don't besides theoretical guidance yes
so that to tuning parameters unlike
estimation from ID data where you only
choose parameter lambda here you have
the bandwidth of your kernel and
parameter london tipton for sparsely
finish piecewise colonel approach
piecewise continuity one was for
smoothly
so they'd hear me using smoothly
changing a 12 very similar structure is
that how big of a H was their current
using essentially the same data or is it
is it how there o is very low relative
to these terms I don't remember off top
of my head had I I don't know but I so
the the debate which was Colonel way it
was a medium distance between all
pairwise distances so roughly you had
some constant fraction of data points
and you had this sliding window so
likely that there were only a few points
that we use here we used here as well
okay so so this is just to illustrate
how what couldn't use the algorithm to
get networks that change over time which
could not be done by just inferring mark
network using as if these observations
variety another case another sort of
things that we could do with this is
here on the right hand side we can we
are putting no interactions but engine
so somebody has performing experience
and this they found out that two genes
to interact and then what we're doing is
the blue points at our the output of an
algorithm where that I just put in time
when these two genes interact and then
we can go and validate for example msn
and dog are out there I mean first this
is an edge during the embryo phase which
can serve be justified by the fact that
these two genes are related to the shape
of an embryo
and for example for SNL n yeah they
these two genes interactive drive
development of multiplies in a fruit fly
okay so this is again how one could use
to explore a complex system men who gain
some insights on about interactions that
otherwise you wouldn't be able to okay
and then maybe just to conclude with
some theoretical results you can obtain
here we sort of owe can prove things
that we would like to serve one would
hope to be able to obtain so under some
suitable assumptions one can show that
so I'm talking about the smoothly
changing networks so if we assume enough
things then we can estimate the graph at
certain time point consistently the high
probability and so the conditions are
standard in the late return hide initial
estimation in particular we require that
the model is identifiable meaning that
the population version of patient
information matrix is satisfies certain
coherence conditions we require the
correlations between two components are
smooth functions over time so in
particular we assume that the the
secondary earth is uniformly bounded by
a constant Colonel satisfy some
regularity conditions and then if the
parameters are chosen in the sort of an
optimal way the graph is going to be
recorded correctly these two assumptions
required telling us that the node degree
cannot be too large well this tells us
that partial correlations for the
elements of the precision matrix that
are too close to zero will be likely
missed out by an estimation procedure
okay so with this so include and any
other questions
bye